Cassian Andor lives before the battle of Yavin
in the year BBY 5. But he doesn't know that,
because the pivotal 'Star Wars' event this
system of time is based on is still years away.
Time is a fleeting concept, one that becomes
even more amorphous when considering how it might
function across an entire galaxy. According to
NASA, our Milky Way galaxy is thought to contain
somewhere between 100 to 400 billion stars, and
measures 100,000 light years in length. This
means that if you were so inclined to travel from
one edge of our galaxy to another, it would take
100,000 years of traveling at the speed of light
to reach the other side. Needless to say, the
vastness of space can be something of a daunting
prospect regarding the conventions of time.
"Andor" is Disney's latest romp through
its flagship "Star Wars" universe,
chronicling how Cassian Andor becomes the
die-hard rebel leader featured in "Star Wars:
Rogue One." Time-wise, "Andor" is a prequel
television series that takes place before the
original "Star Wars" trilogy but after the "Star
Wars" prequel trilogy, placing its story smack
dab in the midst of a fermenting rebellion. More
specifically, the very first moments of "Andor"
see Cassian walking into a city on Morlana One,
and the show mentions that this is taking place
during "BBY 5." Obviously, that denotes a
year. However, what exactly does BBY 5 mean?
In the real world, our calendar categorizes
years as either the secular "BCE" and "CE,"
referring to the "Common Era," or "BC"
or "AD," which is a system heavily
influenced by Christianity. B.C. stands
for "before Christ," while A.D. is Latin
for "anno domini," which translates
to "in the year of the lord." So,
what does "BBY" mean in "Star Wars?" Could
it mean "before Baby Yoda," for example?
Unfortunately, no, Grogu is not part of
the Star Wars dating system. However,
BBY does reference an incredibly historic moment
in the "Star Wars" universe: The Battle of Yavin.
For the non-hardcore "Star Wars" fans, Yavin
IV is the moon that hosts the secretive base
of the Rebel Alliance in the first "Star
Wars" movie. The Battle of Yavin refers
to the skirmish that results in the
destruction of the first Death Star.
"Lock S-Foils in attack position."
This means that "Andor" takes place five years
before this momentous event. This is a victory
that Cassian Andor is partially responsible
for. In "Rogue One" he aids in the theft of
the original Death Star plans. By stealing these
plans, Cassian and the rest of his team provide
the Rebel Alliance with the means to destroy the
Death Star, which otherwise would have become
yet another symbol of Imperial oppression. From
that point on, years in the "Star Wars" universe
are denoted as "Before the Battle of Yavin," aka
BBY, or "After the Battle of Yavin," aka "ABY."
Cassian Andor and the rest of the characters
featured throughout "Andor," of course,
do not know they exist in the year BBY 5, given
that the Battle of Yavin has yet to occur.
According to books like 2015's "Star Wars:
Absolutely Everything You Need to Know," galactic
authorities at one point considered year zero to
be the end of the Old Republic era featured in,
for example, the acclaimed "Star Wars"
video game "Knights of the Old Republic."
An interesting note is that the way
time passes on what was once the
galactic capital Coruscant is akin to
how time passes on Earth, meaning that
a standard year in the "Star Wars" universe
similarly consists of 365 days of 24 hours.
The Old Republic era, meanwhile,
ends at around BBY 1000. So,
if Cassian indeed uses the system that considers
the end of the Old Republic as year zero during
the events of "Andor," he likely understands
himself to exist somewhere around the year
995. Sometime after the Battle of Yavin, the
BBY/ABY system is introduced to the galaxy,
eventually granting its inhabitants the same
timekeeping device frequently shown to viewers.